Maxine:
The Palm Royale, the most exclusive club in the world,
was where I belonged.
♪♪
Man:
How did you get past security?
I came in the back.
There are no doors on
Man:
the back of the Palm Royale.
Ugh!
[thud]
I never said I used the door.
♪♪
Maxine:
I had only been in Palm Beach two weeks.
We don't know you.
I'm Maxine Dellacorte.
Maxine:
But I already knew the Palm Royale,
the most exclusive club in
Maxine:
the world was where I belonged.
Evelyn, you are the
woman to know in Palm Beach.
I don't like you, Maxine.
Dinah:
You're very good at
making things awkward.
Virginia:
I don't concern myself with the
shenanigans of vapid poons.
[glasses clink]
♪♪
Dinah:
What is Evelyn wearing?
Sleeves.
[Hahahaha!]
♪♪
Do you know anything about rich people?
I parked in the lawn.
Norma:
Robert!
Shake me another martini, and then let's play doctor.
Do you work, Maxine?
God, no.
You want to work?
Linda:
You really want all this?
More than anything I've
ever wanted in my whole life.
I'd like to take a few pictures.
Maxine, you're the lead story!
Maxine:
I see us all as one sisterhood.
[LAUGHTER]
♪Are people looking for something new?♪
Evelyn:
Let me tell you
a little something about the Palm Royale.
It's a nightmare.
And that's all thanks to you.
Don't underestimate a Dellacorte.
I would never.
♪♪
Palm Beach is just a shell game.
Linda:
Everybody has a secret.
You two behave.
Robert:
You don't have to have money.
The blackmail is right here.
You don't know the half of it.
What in fires of hell’s pits is going on here?!
Off we go.
♪♪
Linda:
You’re in over your head.
And girl, you don’t even know it.
I am never in over my head.
It would be disrespectful to my hairdresser.
Touché.
♪♪
Maxine:
In Palm Beach,
a secret is like a loaded gun.
No, no, no no.
[Punches]
Maxine:
You never know when it will go off...
Ahh!
♪♪
Maxine:
…Or who it might hit.
♪♪
[Gunshot]
Ladies!
[fingers snap]
I know, yes, surprised to see me,
considering you left me for dead.
♪♪